un nouveau médiateur dans la crise entre
la russie et l'ukraine le président turc
tente une approche reach est hyper doan
est à kiev ce jeudi la turquie est un
allié militaire des ukrainiens elle est
aussi proche des russes la france
également se mobilisent puisque le
président macron n'exclut pas de se
rendra à moscou pour rencontrer vladimir
poutine d'ailleurs il ya un nouveau coup
de fil qui est prévue ce jeudi entre les
deux hommes l'enjeu c'est d'éviter la
guerre la guerre qui est dans toutes les
têtes en ukraine surtout dans les
régions séparatistes
là où vous vous trouvez gulliver crack
bonjour du leader vous êtes dans le
donbass comment se prépare-t-on
alors pour la précision je ne suis pas
dans la partie
séparatistes si on veut employer cette
arme du donbass je suis juste côté
ukrainien mais je suis h astia qui est
une ville sur la ligne de front est une
ville stratégique puisque elle a une
centrale nucléaire en fait je suis
justement la centrale nucléaire mais
vous ne la voyez pas derrière moi elle
est devant moi parce que les soldats qui
la garde ne veulent pas que leur
position soit filmé soit dévoilé la
centrale est gardé par l'armée il y à de
nombreux abris on me dit sur le
territoire de la centrale électrique
mais cela est le cas depuis 2014 en 2014
cette centrale avaient été touchés par
des obus j'ai vu les traces de ces obus
tout à l'heure mais l'armée ici le
message qu'ils veulent transmettre
surtout c'est que rien n'a vraiment
changé depuis 2000 14 depuis 2014 cette
guerre dont le dôme base continue avec
des pics avec des hauts et des bas en
terme d'intensité et qu' ils sont
toujours là ils sont toujours prêts la
réalité c'est que dans nos zones basses
2022 ce début d'année a été relativement
tranquille par rapport à l'année 2000 21
il y a eu moins des chats fourrés cette
année qu'il n'y avait en moyens l'année
dernière
un mot de la diplomatie je le disais à
kiev on s'active puisque le président
zelensky reçoit son homologue turc recep
tayyip erdogan on peut attendre quoi de
cette nouvelle rencontre
alors
tentative de médiation par les turcs
avaient vu avec une certaine inquiétude
par les autres alliés de l'ukraine au
sein de l'otan puisque elles n'ont pas
les meilleures relations avec la turquie
en ce moment à cause des violations des
droits de l'homme et des principes de la
démocratie en turquie est aussi on se
demande aussi qu'elles sont réellement
les relations entre le président et
antoine et vladimir poutine mais en tout
cas officiellement il a condamné
l'agression russe envers l'ukraine et il
voudrait se positionner comme médiateur
on va voir ce que ça donne une chose
concrète qui va être normalement signer
aujourd'hui c'est un accord entre les
deux pays pour que les drones un turc
bayraktar soient produits sous licence
en ukraine merci beaucoup aux golfeurs
craque donc dans le donbass près de la
frontière près de la zone séparatiste
merci pour cette précision là